gut versteckt unter fast vier kilometer
dicken eisschichten hat ein schottisches
forschungsteam jetzt eine unglaubliche
entdeckung gemacht 91 vulkane wovon der
grösste knapp 4000 meter hoch ist noch
nicht klar ob sie derzeit aktiv sind
oder wie hoch das risiko ist für ihn
nahe zukunft aktiv werden
fest steht aber eine eruption könnte
verheerende folgen für die ganze
menschheit haben wie die vulkane genau
entdeckt worden sind was man bisher über
sie weit und welche gefahr von ihnen
ausgeht jetzt im blick zum zweiten
wechsel herzlich willkommen mit dem
vulkan kilimandscharo london ag und
vielen anderen aktiven vulkan galt
bislang ostafrika als die region der
erde mit der größte vulkandichte doch
diesen rang können sie ihnen eine
bestimmte region in der antarktis jetzt
ablaufen konkret geht es um das
sogenannte west antarktis system ist
verläuft etwa 3500 kilometer vom an
aktiv ross schelfeis bis zur
antarktischen halbinsel des gilt
tatsächlich als eines der am wenigsten
untersuchten gebiete der erde schon vor
knapp 20 jahren war dort ein vulkan
entdeckt worden
der wohl vor etwa 2300 jahren
ausgebrochen sein muss geologisch man
dem anschlag ein team der engelbert
university suchte auch von dessen nach
weiteren spuren die auf vulkane
hinweisen könnten
typisch geformten körper sind
tatsächlich aus der luft zu erkennen es
halt sie aus dem eis heraus fragen oft
halten sich jedoch unter einer kilometer
dicken eisschicht versteckt deswegen
helfen sich die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler anders und analysierten
vorherige studien in denen raba signale
protokolliert worden waren
denn diese sind in der lage die dicke
eisdecke zu durchdringen und können so
hinweise auf mögliche basaltfelsen geben
bereit gestein entsteht kurz
zusammengefasst wenn magma an der
erdoberfläche erkaltet und sich an bäume
steine oder mineralien dabei anschließen
ihre ergebnisse werteten sie dann in
hinblick auf weitere satelliten daten
aus anderen studien aus und wie waren
selbst total überrascht von dem ergebnis
dass vier kilometer dicke verdeckt 138
vulkane 91 davon waren bislang noch
unbekannt der kleinste von ihnen mit ein
der größte sind etwa so groß wie der
schweizerische aigner also knapp 4000
meter hoch und die nun 138 bekannten
vulkane dort werden wohl nicht die
einzigen sein die eisdecke wird
höchstwahrscheinlich noch mehr
vulkankegel verstecken so die ansicht
des forschungsteams ihre entdeckung ist
wirklich sehr spannend und faszinierend
auch ein bisschen beängstigend wie
könnte zeigen wie sich der kontinent
während zurückliegender klimatischer
wechsel verändert hat zudem könnten die
vulkane hinweise darauf geben welchen
einfluss sie auf die eisdecke und damit
auch auf den meeresspiegel haben bislang
kann das forschungsteam noch nicht
abschätzen ob die neu entdeckten vulkane
derzeit aktiv sind
doch dies ist tatsächlich eine info die
ist schnellstmöglich herauszufinden gilt
wenn die aktivität der vulkane könnte
verheerende auswirkungen haben die
eisdecke könnte instabil werden und dies
hätte weitere unabsehbare konsequenzen
sollte es zu einer eruption kommt wäre
diese nicht unbedingt an der oberfläche
der als decke erkennbar allerdings würde
das als direkt über dem vulkan im
erheblichen umfang schmelzen was zu
einem anstieg des meeresspiegels führen
könnte so das forschungsergebnis
außerdem könnte die eisdecke deutlich
stabilisiert werden
diese vorstellung macht die geologen
tatsächlich etwas mit ihrer theorie
falls die einzige abnimmt könnte dies
wiederum eine erhöhte vulkanische
aktivität zur folge haben denn ohne die
eisdecke könnte der druck in der region
nachlassen und die vulkane aktiv werden
lassen
das worst case szenario wäre dann eine
kettenreaktion die zusätzlich zu dem
durch den klimawandel ausgelösten
anstieg des meeresspiegels einen
weiteren anstieg verursachen würde
eine absolute katastrophe hierbei klicks
um halte ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden was die forscher noch
herausfinden werden wenn ihr kein video
zum thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit der südpol zerbricht da
geht es um die dramatischen
veränderungen in der arktis liga aktuell
passiert sind sehr sehr interessant also
nicht packen und braucht klicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt